mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
noch immer beherrscht die korona
pandemie uns in alltag und es scheint
kein ende in sicht oder ist vielleicht
der ganze spuk schon bald vorbei
brauchte seine impfpflicht um aus der
krise zu finden oder wäre diese eine
nicht akzeptierbare verletzung der
persönlichen freiheit der haut mit einer
pandemie tür hält und war als billige
potenzielle über
den anspruch wieder zum tragen die
freiheit geht's nicht es geht um
persönliche freiheit kapazität es gut
teilt bestätigen über medizinische hilfe
in der eigenen körper
kulturplatz schlägt den bogen zu
jeremias gotthelf der bereits im
neunzehnten jahrhundert mit seinem roman
das impfen propagierte
parallele sie für mich ganz wichtig
dass man verteuerung der die gleiche
problem qualität also seit dem scanner
kasse
die
kkk wissenschaft nach der fortschritt
und so weiter
[Musik]
wie kommen auf den kulturplatz ja wir
zählen bald das ja drei seit ausbruch
der pandemie und noch immer hoffen wir
dass es einfach bald vorbei sein möge
doch die zahlen der neuinfektionen sie
sprechen leider eine andere sprache und
die debatte um eine mögliche impfpflicht
reißt einen gesellschaftlichen graben
auf der das thema impfen es war schon
immer hoch emotional einst schrieb sogar
ihre mias gotthelf einen roman um seine
landsleute möglichst von der
pockenimpfung zu überzeugen und auch
heute noch beschäftigt uns diese frage
persönliche freiheit versus solidarität
dieser frage gehen wir heute nach und
machen station hier am soziologischen
institut der uni zürich
[Musik]
je länger die partie dauerte umso
drängender wird die frage wie schützen
wir gleichzeitig die gesellschaft und
aber auch die rechte des einzelnen
selbst ethikerin und philosophen sind
sich hier uneins klar ist die werte der
demokratie werden mit cockpit richtig
hart auf die probe gestellt
omikron die neueste variante des corona
virus verbreitet sich so schnell wie
keine variante davor die
infektionszahlen steigen rasant der
ausgang ist ungewiss
doch die krankheitsverläufe scheinen
weniger heftig die intensivbetten sind
noch nicht ausgelastet ein grund dafür
eine mehrheit der bevölkerung ist
geimpft auch wenn es im durchbrüche gibt
für wissenschafter steht außer frage
dass die impfung uns vor dem kollaps
bewahrt für christine sieht in der sein
team zieht es überhaupt jetzt der winter
rooney lockte
besitz bestand und dass ich enorm
mcqueen für die ganze gesellschaft oder
das alles was in köln stattfindende
veranstaltung im
restaurant kulturveranstaltungen
stattfinden
finden dank dem stand
soll sich jeder und jede impfen lassen
müssen so weit es medizinisch vertretbar
ist damit die öffentliche gesundheit
garantiert und das leben weitergehen
kann es geht um die verantwortung des
einzelnen bürgers für die gemeinschaft
und um die pflicht des staates diese
gemeinschaft zu schützen
für den politischen philosophen francis
schöne wahl ist klar der einzelne da für
das gemeinwohl keine gefahr sein
perfide nicht dass bürgerinnen und
bürger das gefühl hätte genügend lebens
gemacht und sie sie gerne gefeiert und
da darf man die freiheit war nicht ich
denke aber wenn man selber unter
betragen vom nil virus gefährliches
pflaster ist dazu zählt philosophiert
aber wenn der wie das kleinlich ist wenn
die denn die frankreich ist es mir aber
gefahr für andere um denen sie große
freiheit ich denke die maßnahme
verantwortbar
doch wie weit sollen maßnahmen gehen
schon das neue cockpit gesetzt und jetzt
die 2g regeln für viele orte in der
öffentlichkeit stoßen in der breiten
bevölkerung auf widerstand
auch intellektuelle wie die
schriftstellerin sibylle berg wehren
sich gegen die einschränkungen der
freiheit durch den staat
einen beschränkten zugang zum
öffentlichen leben hält sie für sehr
gefährlich
doch kann der bürger wenn er selbst zur
gefahr für andere wird auf seine
individuelle freiheit pochen
wenn man halt mit der pandemie tür hält
und man als bürger potenziell
übertragenen ansprache
wieder zu betragen die frage ist nicht
mit aber das moralisch geboten einander
die ähnliche der gesundheit schädigen
moral ist das eine die regierung hat die
pflicht die öffentlichen güter zu
schützen unter anderem die gesundheit
der bevölkerung
sind die spitäler überlastet und kann
die grundversorgung ärztlicher
dienstleistungen nicht gewährleistet
werden muss der staat eingreifen
spricht er wie in österreich eine
impfpflicht aus dann setzt er das
gemeinwohl über das recht der
unversehrtheit des eigenen körpers
ist eine solche entscheidung ethisch
vertretbar
[Musik]
für die präsidentin des nationalen
ethikrates würde ein solcher entscheid
so massiv in die rechte des einzelnen
eingreifen
was
auf dem spiel steht ich habe relativ
viel es geht um persönliche freiheit
körperliche integrität dass gott selbst
bestimmen über medizinische liege und er
eigenen körper das ist eigentlich sehr
hohes gut das klima in der gesamte
rechts nicht da gibt es ganz wenige
situationen wo man die
entscheidungsfreiheit nicht mit rico für
medizinische maßnahmen über eigene
körper so das ist eigentlich glaube
wirklich sehr viel auf dem spiel ist
omikron gefährlich genug um einen
körperlichen eingriff zu rechtfertigen
ist die im forderung angemessen aus der
sicht des politischen philosophen ist
der pieks den bürger ihnen zumutbar
sondern momentan im
mini und verzeiht ins verhältnis muss
bringt zur rede
also dann muss sie da muss die
unversehrtheit und betrachtet sie ihren
mini in betracht sich dass das team
moralische gleich es ist der frack vor
390 bin ich verpflichtet muslime zu
riskieren für die leute aber mit der
bahre bühler stramme also körperlich
fast unversehrt sich nicht sagen
dass ich sie auch dem 4 nieder und die
körperliche schädigung somit ja also
jeder jetzt bauen oder nach dem kicker
das ist eigentlich im final und ist
zudem möglich
verhindert
doch die impfskepsis kann man nicht
einfach wegwischen und der dialog der
austausch von argumenten das zuhören
können haben es in einer äußerst
emotional geführten debatte sehr schwer
also zunächst mal halte ich jetzt
wirklich für fatal und für falsch
menschen zu kriminalisieren die von
ihrem recht gebrauch machen eingriffe in
ihren körper abzulehnen und ich wehre
mich auch dagegen dass man die
ungeimpften hinstellt also eine
unterschiedslose dummes kollektiv die
ungeimpften also es gibt doch sehr
unterschiedliche motive sie haben das
gerade schon angedeutet warum menschen
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen und das
ist eine abwägungsfrage und das ist
nicht gegen die eigene vernunft sondern
das ist man nennt das selbstbestimmung
wenn wir die position von allgemeiner
ntp familie wenn wir das frage meint uwe
barth pandemie perpetuieren und damit
die möglicherweise notwendige maßnahmen
für
total
grundsätzlich stehen aber die hoffnung
wirtschaftssystems verhinderte also mit
uhrzeit kann auch von der eigenen
freiheit schuf rohmer nati wenn man sich
nicht und trotzdem können
was wenn omikron nicht die letzte welle
ist sind dann wiederholte
einschränkungen für die gesellschaft
tolerierbar weil sich ein teil von ihr
nicht impfen lässt
ein gesetzesvorschlag für die
impfpflicht könnte helfen die debatte
würde dann an der urne weitergeführt
[Musik]
katja roose sind soziologin an der
universität zürich wie geht es uns dann
aus gesellschaft jetzt nach zwei jahren
mit so manchem großen tiefpunkt würde
ich sagen geht es mittlerweile besser
wieso geht es uns jetzt besser wo wir
noch zwei jahre leiden weil es soziale
leben die daten gefangen hat und die
leute
neben hier also auch ein kalkuliertes
risiko im griff um eben wieder in
schwimmbäder zu gehen um ski zu fahren
um ins restaurant zu gehen um sich also
auch privat zu treffen und das ist für
menschen einfach extrem wichtig also
dass die sozialen kontakte können wieder
stattfinden die außenwelt kann wieder
stattfinden gleichzeitig haben das wort
risiko genannt wir haben vielleicht
gelernt anders mit risiken umzugehen ist
das so die leute haben gelernt quasi mit
dieser unsicherheit zum teil eben
umzugehen und eben hier ist einmal das
zu machen was schützt aber dann auch zu
sagen okay jetzt schließe ich mich nicht
einen meiner wohnung also nicht alle ja
muss man sagen es gibt manche die dort
sehr risikoaversen aber ein großer teil
der bevölkerung nimmt am sozialen leben
beta 3 es gibt es ja seit letztem herbst
in der schweiz jedenfalls ist das tabu
der impfpflicht gefallen man diskutiert
darüber ob das sinnvoll wäre die
ethikkommission in der schweiz ist
dagegen in deutschland dafür was sagen
die soziologen zu einer möglichen
impfpflicht die soziologie als das zum
team seit gar nicht das ist also
wirklich eine sache von ethik aber was
man hier aus soziologischer sicht eben
sagen kann ist dass ich hier natürlich
ich sag mal dass man investiert was
wissenschaft ausmacht über wissenschaft
ist eben selten schwarz weiß und das ist
für die bevölkerung häufig schwer
nachvollziehbar ja also unterschiedliche
entscheidungen und daraus kann dann auch
häufig eben wut und unverständnis
entstehen und das sieht man in allen
ländern das hier quasi die bevölkerung
zum teil auch damit überfordert ist mit
diesen sehr widersprüchlichen urteilen
eben von den experten ja und von den
politikerinnen ja und ständig wieder
eben neuen informationen und das ist
eben was spezielles an dieser krise sie
haben gesagt es geht uns eigentlich
insgesamt besser aber dann doch mit
dieser der umgang mit dieser
unsicherheit ist das etwas was sich
zuspitzen könnte nein weil der mensch
ist ja lernfähig das sollte man nicht
unterschätzen und diese unsicherheit
begleitet uns jetzt zwei jahre her und
wir haben lernen müssen damit umzugehen
und jeder hat da unterschiedliche
strategien entwickelt ja und ich glaube
die menschen entwickeln strategien die
ihn selber gut tun und jemand der eben
sagt okay mir ist das soziale leben
wichtiger ja ich brauch das ja und geht
deswegen ein kalkuliertes risiko einer
dem tut das brot und jemand anderes der
eben sagt nein also ich hab da so eine
angst ja also von monaco wird erkrankung
in dem macht es auch weniger aus wer zu
hause zu bleiben danke fürs erste
kategorie
ja wir alle erinnern uns an den song von
polo hofer in der stop aids kampagne dem
siebten sprung im minimum ein gummi
traum so erfolgreich sind die aktuellen
versuche der regierung die prominenz
einzubeziehen in die impf debatte noch
nicht doch ähnliche versuche gab es
bereits im 19 jahrhundert damals
beauftragte die berner regierung den
schriftsteller jeremias gotthelf eine
schrift zu verfassen welche die bauern
im emmental vom sinn der pockenimpfung
überzeugen sollte
lützelflüh im emmental
im neunzehnten jahrhundert lebte hier im
pfarrhaus ein mann der seine
zeitgenossen für unbelehrbar hielt einer
der bedeutendsten autoren seiner zeit
ihre mias gotthilf im hauptberuf fahrer
daneben war er journalist volks
aufklärer roman autor
einst beauftragte ihn die berner
regierung eine schrift gegen den
aberglauben zu verfassen gotthelf sagte
da steckt viel mehr drin so entstand
seien umfangreiche roman anna bio werke
es ist die geschichte einer impf
gegnerin
saberi hat gesagt dass kruse im spiel so
dem armen unschuldigen kind express
schmerzen zu machen und müsste man doch
nicht ob es eigentlich nötig wäre oder
nicht und ich habe bei mir selbst
gedacht das sei so eine neue mode und
wenn der liebe gott nicht gewollt hätte
dass die kinder die platten bekommen
sollten so hätte sie nicht kommen lassen
hättet ihr ihn impfen lassen so wäre
alles das nicht aber so seid ihr zur
rechten zeit könnt ihr nichts tun und
wenn dann alles vertuscht ist durch eure
schuld so soll der doktor alles
wiedergutmachen
[Applaus]
das nicht mehr da hatte ich echt was nur
ist da nicht ein wenig mehrwert
erbringt sie hätte einziger sohn das
ärgerte sich maßlos
sie und da erkrankt aber
ab ob und wie sie eigentlich die normale
medizin
misstraut gc zu pushen und sie nimmt
sich auf das
jakobi
mein haar steht dass er schlägt vor dem
poker geschichte des formats geschichte
ist es einmal brennt hasenfuß das
schönburg wo sie also
deutsche sitzen
doch alle baby lernt daraus nichts
beim enkelkind verhält sie sich noch
einmal genauso
der bub erkrankt an diphtherie auch eine
schwere solche die in dieser zeit
grassierte die
tier macht sie genau die gleiche farbe
studie griefahn
geht es dazu der kultur und des
vertrauens zu den arzt und jetzt steht
das ein koring
tragisch die folgen dabei schwer zu
akzeptieren für die bauern die kühe
brachten die kuhpocken in die welt
der englische arzt edward jenner wollte
gegen ende des achtzehnten jahrhunderts
die pocken besiegen eine furchtbare
krankheit mit hohen todeszahlen jenna
initiierte einem achtjährigen das sekret
einer puppe in die haut der junge wurde
immun
1-sieg der wissenschaft
mit kuhpocken
impfgegner gründeten weltweit vereine
sie sagten durch eine pockenimpfung
wachsen einem corner aus dem leib
sehr schnell wurde die pockenimpfung
vielerorts zur pflicht für heinrich
schütz ist klar ihre mias gotthelf
erklärt die gegenwart
logo wirkt es als modewort lombok
ersetzte nok also zu nahe biete sich die
parallele sie filme ganz ähnlicher form
auch dass man verteuerung der die
gleiche problem qualität
und unter sich die dankesworte also
seitdem sky knicks
die gattin cover der wissenschaft nach
der fortschritt und sollte
genau wo ich eigentlich hieß gotthelf
albert beziehungs und schrieb unter
pseudonym man hat ihn unweit seines
pfarrhauses beerdigt
von dort aus kann er predigen gegen die
wissenschafts ungläubigen dieser welt
katar ist also schon zu gotthelfs zeiten
gab es viel skepsis gegenüber der
medizin gegenüber der wissenschaft dass
es heute nicht viel anders geworden
wieso ist das so in uns eingepflanzt
ja also ich glaube da gibt es
verschiedene ursachen das kann man jetzt
nicht so auf den punkt bringen also viel
spielt dabei eine rolle dass ich sagen
hat das volk sich häufig eben auf einer
anderen position befindet als die
sogenannten eliten ja also und dass man
hier die gegenüber den eliten auch
skeptisch ist ja was die eben einen
sagen wollen ja und dass man dem nicht
ganz so vertraut und insofern könnte man
das jetzt quasi ein bisschen weiter auch
nach oben ziehen und könnte sagen es
geht nicht um wissenschaft skepsis
sondern es geht also um die skepsis
gegenüber den eliten und das können also
politiker das können wissenschaftler
oder eben auch wirtschaftsführer sein wo
man hier es gibt sich ist jetzt auch in
der gesellschaft selbst ist der graben
sich am vertiefen ja in befürworter und
skeptiker
was können wir tun damit sich dieser
graben nicht noch mehr verstärkt
vielleicht jeder einschläfern und
ja also jeder einzelne kann haben wir
damit dafür tun indem man so tolerant
ist ja und diese toleranz ja das ist
immer so einfach gesagt ja toleranz
bedeutet eben auch eine entscheidung von
einer anderen person eben wirklich zu
akzeptieren erst mal
so eben auch zu akzeptieren wenn ich zb
einer person gegenüber stehe die sich
eben nicht impfen lassen möchte zum
beispiel der französische
staatspräsident manuel mata hat es nicht
so mit der toleranz er will die
impfgegner
mrd wir gesagt hat und auch hier in der
gesellschaft nimmt man das war es gibt
sogar familien wo es ein graben gibt ja
im unter eheleuten usw freundschaften
die darunter leiden was wäre da ihr
vater soziologin wie es der umgang dann
im ganz kleinen bereich
eigentlich muss sozusagen das war eben
darüber nicht sprechen sollte ja dann
über solche themen also sei er eben über
themen sprechen sollte wo man mir
gemeinsame basis findet davon gibt es
sehr viele ja auch in den familien ja
und ich sage jetzt wird es ebenso sehr
stark auf dieses impft hier mal eben
nach oben gekocht ja da gibt es doch
ganz andere themen auch die familie
neben spalten da müssen wir dann
wirklich auch sagen okay lass uns nicht
mehr darüber reden sondern lasst uns ein
neues thema suchen haben sie die
befürchtung dass sich eine verhärtung
auch noch mehr etablieren könnte jetzt
mit dieser frage gerade mit der in frage
wenn das so weitergeht
natürlich ist das möglich ja wenn
vorausgesetzt die welt läuft so häufig
wie heute aber wir können ja jetzt auch
ein bisschen optimistisch zum beispiel
in die zukunft schauen dass eventuell
die lage sich jetzt entspannt auch mit
corona er irgendwann mal und dann
sozusagen sollte sich dieses thema auch
entspannen ja ja schon lange weile dass
ich jetzt hoffen wir dass
[Musik]
ja an der in frage kann sich leicht ein
heißer konflikt entfachen bis einer zu
den waffen greift nein nicht hier und
heute zum glück aber so geschehen vor
gut 200 jahren als sich tirol auflehnte
gegen die besatzungsmacht bayern der
zündende funke damals eine drohende
impfpflicht
tiefen tälern konzert jeher was die welt
bewegt
der kampf um freiheit in tirol steht
dafür andreas hofer
[Musik]
innsbruck hauptstadt des
österreichischen bundeslandes tirol
auf dem bergisel steht das museum tirol
panorama auf dem weg in die schlacht auf
über 1000 quadratmetern stellte der
maler michael zeno dieter dzewas
1809 am bergisel geschah
hier kämpften die tiroler um die
freiheit gegen die bayern gegen die
franzosen gegen die fremdherrschaft
gegen vorschriften von ganz oben
die bayern sagte der tiroler lasst euch
impfen gegen die pocken ob ihr wollt
oder nicht
eine impfpflicht
es erinnert an die gegenwart
ich glaube gar nicht dass es jetzt bei
dem freiheitskampf tirol gegen die
bayern so sehr ums impfen geht es geht
darum dass ein staat eine maßnahme
einführt und damit sozusagen auch zeigt
werde gut auf hat und das ist das was
mit dem impfen verbunden wird und zwar
auf beiden seiten die bayern die
tatsächlich das als ihre errungenschaft
eben
einbringen durchsetzen wollen um zu
zeigen wer macht hier politik und die
tiroler die sozusagen diesen angriff
abwehren wollen und eben am impfen
sozusagen dieser freiheitskampf
aufbricht ich glaube gar nicht dass es
so sehr ums impfen nur geht sondern vor
allem um ganz andere fragen nämlich wer
hier eigentlich jetzt chef im ring ist
sozusagen
andreas hofer freiheitskämpfer es gibt
corona leugner die seen inhofer einen
kämpfer für ihre ganz spezielle ansicht
von freiheit sie sagen hofer wollte sich
nicht gegen die pocken impfen lassen
andreas hofer impfgegner nicht in
unserem heutigen sind ein impfgegner
sondern ein bayern-gegner ein franzosen
gegner
der sich gegen diese verordnung gewährt
hat bis heute nimmt man verordnungen
nicht gern entgegen ich bin der skiort
in tirol es ist der beginn des zweiten
pandemischen winters in dieser skisaison
steht man hier sozusagen unter bewährung
verordnungen sollen ordnung schaffen
zu zeiten des tiroler freiheitskampfes
hatte man das erste mittel gegen die
pocken gefunden schon damals vor über
200 jahren gab es verschiedene
vorstellungen davon was freiheit ist im
spiel war dies bis zum beginn von corona
der exzess
ausmaß wie dem kids loch entsprangen
nachweislich die ersten 11.000
infektionen europas
solche bilder will man in diesem winter
nicht mehr sehen
der ort tut alles um das image des
corona hotspots loszuwerden
und eben die freiheit heute heißt das
oft ich möchte machen was ich will
nirgends lassen sich weniger menschen
impfen als in den freiheitsliebenden
bergregionen
noch ist die impfung freiwillig ab
februar sollte in österreich eine
impfpflicht für alle gelten doch omikron
bringt den zeitplan ins wanken
an der universität innsbruck schaut man
zurück
freiheitsliebend sind die tiroler bis
heute und gleichzeitig erzkatholisch
eine schwierige sache
der klerus befürwortet die impfung weil
der klerus in dieser zeit teil des
staates geworden ist
vorbehalte finden wir er also in der
bevölkerung wir haben religiöse gründe
um kinder nicht zu impfen und auch ein
soziales motiv
viele kinder sind ein problem für ärmere
familien
das heißt es ist oft ein segen wenn
weniger kinder das erwachsenenalter
erreichen
andreas hofer trieb noch ganz anderes um
als das impfen
mit modernen waffen gegen
althergebrachte
das mit dem freiheitskampf ging richtig
schief andreas hofer wurde von den
franzosen geschnappt und hingerichtet hd
mein land tirol
da half kein göttlicher segen
aber immerhin das virus der freiheit war
in der welt
freiheit in tirol wird seit jeher darum
gekämpft
auch die sternstunde philosophie widmet
sich am sonntag der frage der
impfpflicht versus persönliche freiheit
und gleich jetzt nach und vp auf sf1
auch eine sternstunde zum thema
klimawandel
ja und wir wir sehen uns nächsten
mittwoch wieder dann sprechen wir über
geld kommen sie gut durch die woche
wissen
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos